[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christian in der Fußball
Champions League da sind die nächsten
Partien ausgelöst worden
Manchester City guten Abend und das
haben wir heute außerdem in der Sendung
Diät für den xxl-bundestag die
Ampelkoalition hat das Wahlrecht
reformiert das Parlament schrumpft CSU
und Linke sind empört
Haftbefehl gegen Putin der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof
Russlands Präsidenten wegen
Kriegsverbrechen zur Verantwortung
ziehen
und Wirbelsturm der extreme mehr als
einen Monat zog Zyklon Freddy über die
Südhalbkugel im Osten Afrikas
hinterlässt er Verwüstung und Leid
[Musik]
der Bundestag soll verkleinert werden
wie darüber wurde jahrelang heftig
gestritten heute nun beschloss der
Bundestag mit Ampel Mehrheit eine
Wahlrechtsreform das Parlament soll
künftig von aktuell über 730 dauerhaft
auf 630 Abgeordnete schrumpfen das mit
dem dauerhaft darf aber mit großen
Fragezeichen versehen werden denn linke
und Union sehen sich stark benachteiligt
und wollen klagen Tobias Hafner erklärt
wie das neue Wahlrecht funktionieren
soll
598 Abgeordnete die alle deutschen in
Berlin repräsentieren so ist es
eigentlich gedacht doch über die Jahre
wurde es im Plenarsaal enger derzeit
sitzen dort 736 Volksvertreter Rekord
wegen der sogenannten Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate die gab es bislang
wenn Parteien mehr Direktmandate holten
als Ihnen nach dem Zweitstimmenergebnis
Zustande um das für die anderen Parteien
auszugleichen bekamen auch die
zusätzliche Sitze
Deckel drauf bei 630 Abgeordneten
Schluss mit Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandaten sagt nun die Ampel
das Mittel der Wahl die Erststimme für
die direktsätze wird geschwächt dafür
die Zweitstimme für die Parteien
aufgewertet sie bekommt mehr Gewicht
konkret bekommen nun nicht mehr alle
wahlkreis-gewinner automatisch ein
Mandat sondern nur diejenigen deren Sitz
vom prozentualen Ergebnis ihrer Partei
gedeckt ist die anderen gingen leer aus
dagegen läuft vor allem die csu-sturm
denn einzelne Wahlkreise etwa in München
könnten so künftig nicht mehr im
Bundestag vertreten sein
ja und nicht nur die Union auch die
Linkspartei schäumt und das liegt an
einer Sonderregel zur 5% Hürde die
gekippt werden soll die Wut der
Oppositionsparteien über das
durchdrücken der Wahlrechtsreform durch
die Ampel wurde im Bundestag besonders
deutlich so laut war es dort schon lange
nicht mehr wie heute Andreas hupper
nimmt uns noch mal mit und bringt uns
die Positionen näher
Volker Ulrich CSU-Abgeordnete aus
Augsburg ist sauer Grund die anstehende
Wahlrechtsreform er fürchtet künftig
auch als wahlkreis-gewinner leer
auszugehen das direkt gewählte Bewerber
die in ihren Wahlkreisen siegreich sind
und unter Umständen kein Mandat im
Deutschen Bundestag erhalten das kann
niemanden vermittelt werden CDU und
fahren die CSU haben bislang die meisten
Direktmandate damit war man nach dem
alten Wahlrecht sicher im Bundestag das
soll sich nun zum Ärger der CSU ändern
dieser Versuch der
wahlrechtsmanipulation der verkleinert
das Parlament aber er dient einem
anderen Ziel nämlich den Machtanspruch
der Ampel zu zementieren sie müssen
damit klarkommen dass es auf der Welt
und in diesem Land auch mal einen
einzigen Tag geht an den du es nicht um
die CSU geht sondern um dieses Land
hitzig ist die Debatte heftig der
schlagertausch auch die Linke ist auf
dem Barrikaden es geht um die Grundmann
das Klausel ohne die wäre die Linke
nicht im Bundestag denn das
Bundeswahlgesetz liegt fest eine Partei
die mindestens drei Direktmandate
erreicht erhält Fraktion Status kommt in
den Bundestag auch dann wenn sie die
fünf Prozent hörte reist im neuen
Wahlrecht für die Grundmann das Klausen
gestrichen dass sie mit Änderungsantrag
also hier hin
mal eben kurz zwei Oppositionsparteien
aus dem Bundestag politisch eliminieren
wollen am Ende der Debatte noch ein
Angebot des
cdu-fraktionsschefs dass wir noch mal um
zwei Wochen verschieben um darüber
nachzudenken wie wir dieses Problem so
gemeinsam lösen können dass wir dem Ziel
der gemeinsamen Änderung des
Wahlgesetzes der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland noch einmal näher kommen das
wird nicht besser wenn wir es noch mal
14 Tage über Antworten einer Diskussion
weil die wird am Ende kein Ergebnis
bekommen mit ihrer Mehrheit beschließt
die Ampelkoalition das neue Wahlrecht
Volker Ulrich und seine CSU werden
gemeinsam mit der Linken vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht dagegen klagen
ging also hoch her im Bundestag fragen
wir noch mal nach in Berlin bei Energy
hat sich die Ampel einen Gefallen damit
getan diese so wichtigere Form quasi im
Alleingang durchzudrücken
also man kann schon verstehen dass die
Ampel nach über 10 Jahren ergebnisloser
Verhandlungen heute mal eine
Entscheidung herbeiführen wollte und man
muss ja auch zu gut erhalten dass sie
der Opposition angeboten hat auch nach
der heutigen Abstimmung weitere
Änderungen am Wahlrecht zu diskutieren
die dann mögliche Schwächen des der
heute des heutigen Beschlusses wieder
ausgleichen könnten aber dem
eigentlichen Ziel nämlich mehr Vertrauen
wieder zu schaffen in das Parlament und
in die Demokratie ist man heute hier
nicht näher gekommen da muss man wohl
sagen im Gegenteil denn es drohen jetzt
nicht nur Klagen vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht sondern es
könnte auch noch weitergehen Friedrich
Merz hat ja heute schon für die Union
angekündigt dass wenn er beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht
erfolgreich sein sollte mit einer Klage
bei der nächsten Gelegenheit wo die
Union mitregiert dann auch wieder
Änderungen geben könnte und damit
entsteht natürlich erst recht der
Eindruck dass die Regierenden sich dann
das Wahlrecht so zurecht schustern wie
Sie es gerade haben wollen das ist das
Gegenteil von Wiederherstellen von
Vertrauen man muss es nicht so drastisch
formulieren wie die Opposition ist heute
getan hat den CSU und Linken die haben
von Manipulationen und vom Anschlag aufs
Wahlrecht gesprochen aber der
verfassungswissenschaftler
Verfassungsrechtler Ulrich battes der
hat heute gesagt Frieden hat dieser
Beschluss nicht geschafft heute und das
ist wirklich dann danke nach Berlin
weiter mit dem Hinhörer des Tages der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof in Den
Haag hat Haftbefehl gegen Russlands
Präsidenten Wladimir Putin erlassen er
wirft ihm vor verantwortlich für
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine zu sein
der Strafgerichtshof ist kein Teil der
UNO wird aber von Deutschland und 122
weiteren Ländern anerkannt holen wir
Florian Neuheim in die Sendung Florian
welche Bedeutung hat dieser Haftbefehl
des Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs
das ist erstmal nur ein Symbol aber ich
würde sagen ein ziemlich starkes der
Westen macht damit deutlich dass man die
Kriegsverbrechen Russlands in diesem
Krieg strafrechtlich verfolgen will in
der konkreten Entscheidung von heute
geht es um die Deportation von Kindern
aus der Ukraine und das Gericht sagt
heute es gäbe hinreichende Gründe dafür
anzunehmen dass Putin dafür persönlich
verantwortlich sein soll persönlich aber
wird Putin wohl demnächst kaum vor dem
Gericht in Den Haag erscheinen Russland
erkennt diesen Strafgerichtshof in den
Tag eben nicht an übrigens genau wie
China und auch die USA aber es könnte
künftige Auslandsreisende des russischen
Präsidenten deutlich erschweren nämlich
in Länder die Vertragsparteien des
Strafgerichtshofs sind etwa in die
Europäische Union ohne auch nach
Südafrika dass 2024 den G20 Gipfel
ausrichten wird in diesen Ländern könnte
Putin dann tatsächlich verhaftet werden
danke für die Einordnung Florian
Neuheiten ja der Haftbefehl gegen Putin
auch Thema bei heute live um 19:30 Uhr
auf unseren Social Media Kanälen und in
unserer ZDF heute App
jetzt nach Polen da hat das Land auch
die nach der nach Polen Entschuldigung
hat auch die Slowakei angekündigt
Kampfjets an die Ukraine zu liefern und
dabei handelt es sich um eine Flotte von
13 ausrangierten mit 29 Maschinen drei
von ihnen sollen als Ersatzteillager
dienen als Ausgleich bekommt die
Slowakei von der EU 200 Millionen Euro
sowie Waffen von den USA auch im Wert
von mehreren hundert Millionen
seit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine wollen Schweden und Finnland der
NATO beitreten ein Problem NATO Mitglied
Türkei spielt nicht mit der Vorwurf die
skandinavischen Länder würden zu
nachgiebig mit kurdischen Organisationen
umgehen die in der Türkei als
Terrorvereinigung gelten für Finnland
zumindest könnte der Weg jetzt aber frei
sein Erdogan gibt grünes Licht und
empfängt Finnlands Präsidenten Florian
erneuern
es regnet aus Kübeln in Ankara aber sie
haben einen Schirm für den Gast aus
Finnland es ist das Bild für die
Nachricht des Tages der Schutzschirm der
NATO soll über Finnland ausgebreitet
werden jetzt auch mit Zustimmung der
Türkei
ich bin überzeugt davon dass die NATO
durch den Beitritt Finnlands noch
stärker wird und eine wichtige Rolle
dabei spielen wird weltweit Sicherheit
und Stabilität zu erhalten und jeden Tag
im vergangenen Mai hatten findet und
Schweden angesichts des russischen
Krieges gemeinsam Ihre Bewerbung bei der
NATO eingereicht doch heute gibt der
türkische Präsident sein grünes Licht
bloß für Finnland
ich habe das Gefühl dass die finnische
NATO Mitgliedschaft nicht vollständig
ist ohne Schweden wir haben so viele
gemeinsame Interessen
über Schweden entgegnet Erdogan müsste
man noch nachdenken der türkische
Präsident wirft im Land auch heute vor
das ist zu wenig gegen kurdische
Terroristen im eigenen Land Unternehmen
nach Ansicht der NATO aber hat Schweden
alle Zusagen erfüllt die die Regierung
dazu beim letzten NATO-Gipfel in Madrid
gemacht hatte Nato-Generalsekretär
deutenberg begrüßt auf Twitter die
heutige Entscheidung der Türkei und
betont zugleich dass beide Länder
aufgenommen werden sollen für einen
endgültigen Beitritt muss jetzt das
türkische Parlament zustimmen außerdem
noch jenes aus Ungarn
keine Lehrer kein Unterricht der
Lehrermangel hat dramatische Ausmaße
angenommen das Problem es gibt immer
weniger die das Lehramtsstudium
abschließen die Zahl der Absolventen
ging innerhalb von 10 Jahren auf rund
28.000 900 zurück und gleichzeitig
werden wieder mehr Kinder geboren
hinzu kommen dann noch mehr als 200.000
geflüchtete Kinder aus der Ukraine diese
Entwicklung also mehr Kinder und weniger
Lehrer sorgt für massive Probleme an den
Schulen die uns jetzt Stefanie gagusch
zeigt
[Musik]
Unterricht an einer Schule in einem
sozialen Brennpunkt jeden Tag Ringen Sie
hier mit den Problemen jedes einzelnen
Kindes die Sprache Armut Gewalt in der
Familie dafür erhält die Schule extra
Geld und Unterstützung doch sie finden
kaum noch Lehrkräfte
die Gefahr besteht dass wir die Kinder
ihn nicht so fördern können wie sie es
brauchen das bedeutet dann eben dass sie
nicht den Bildungserfolg haben werden
der wichtig ist um überhaupt ins Leben
starten zu können etwa 4000 solcher
Schulen gibt es in Deutschland sie will
der Bund nun gezielter unterstützen mit
Wohlen maximal 2 Milliarden Euro dem
stimmte die Kultusministerkonferenz der
Länder heute zu außerdem wollen sie
sonderhilfen einführen für besonders
belastete Bundesländer wie etwa Bremen
und Berlin jedes Land soll dafür 5% in
einen voreinzahlen der wird dann da hin
verteilt wo die Bedürftigkeit also am
größten ist andere Länder bezahlen in
diesen
Solidaritätsfonds nur ein und bekommen
keinen Euro daraus das auch schwierige
Schulen erfolgreich sein können zeigt
der rütlich Campus in Neuköln 2006
machte die als brennpunktschule
Schlagzeilen heute ist sie ein
Vorzeigeprojekt all dies gelang mit
einer motivierten Schulleitung
politischen Willen und vielen
Lehrkräften den Lehrermangel etwa durch
Arbeitsverdichtung abzumildern für sie
keine Lösung die Lehrer brauchen gerade
im sozialen Brennpunkt die unterrichten
ja nicht nur sondern die sind ja immer
auch in der Beziehungsarbeit mit Kindern
und Jugendlichen dafür brauchen sie
schlicht und ergreifen Zeit der Schule
Erfolg hängt an allen Schulen von
Lehrkräften ab aber die fehlen Geld
allein wird das nicht lösen
das Thema Bildungs spielt unter anderem
auch eine Rolle im brandneuen ZDF
Politbarometer Antje Pieper ist bei uns
im Studio hallo Antje was ist dabei
rausgekommen ja da ist das Ergebnis sehr
deutlich die Befragten sehen dringend
Handlungsbedarf 91% sagen das in
Deutschland für Schule und Bildung zu
wenig getan wird Bildung ist in
Deutschland ja Ländersache nur 22%
meinen dass das so bleiben sollte drei
Viertel der Befragten wünschen sich dass
der Bund mehr mitbestimmt Antje stand
jetzt ist es ja so dass in der EU ab
2035 keine Diesel und Benziner mehr neu
zugelassen werden dürfen auch dazu bei
euch interessante Zahlen ja das sieht
eine Mehrheit kritisch nur 34 Prozent
sind für ein Verbot der Neuzulassung von
Autos mit Verbrennungsmotor ab 2035 61
Prozent sind dagegen Mehrheiten gegen
das Verbot finden sich bei den Anhängern
aller Parteien nur die der Grünen sind
überwiegend dafür
insgesamt gibt es bei der Stimmung im
Land wenig Bewegung wenn am Sonntag
wirklich Bundestagswahl wäre würden nur
die Grünen leichter zu gewinnen käme auf
19% +1 und die AFD leicht verlieren 14
Prozent minus 1 ansonsten bleibt alles
wie bei der letzten Umfrage damit würde
es für schwarz-rot oder knapp
Schwarz-Grün reichen aktuell aber nicht
für die regierende Ampel dann vielen
Dank Antje für diesen Vorgeschmack und
wie immer gibt es das gesamte
Politbarometer eben heute journal um 22
Uhr für Sie
jetzt der Blick nach Bremen dort darf
die AFD vorerst nicht bei der
Bürgerschaftswahl im Mai antreten so hat
es die zuständige Wahlleitung
entschieden hintergrund ist dass der
tief zerstrittene AFD Landesverband zwei
verschiedene Wahllisten einreichte und
das ist laut Wahlgesetz verboten beide
parteilager wollen Beschwerde gegen
diese Entscheidung einlegen
die deutschen Essen produzieren und
exportieren immer weniger Fleisch das
meldet heute das Statistische Bundesamt
während der Pro kopfkonsum 2011 noch bei
62,8 kg lag waren es zehn Jahre später
55 Kilo neben Ernährungstrends machen
sich aber auch die gestiegenen
Fleischpreise bemerkbar und das im
letzten Jahr vor allem beim Geflügel
quasi im Alleingang ohne Abstimmung im
Parlament hatte Frankreichs Präsident
macron gestern seine umstrittene
Rentenreform durchgesetzt gegen den
Willen sehr vieler Franzosen heute nun
hat die Opposition zwei
misstrauensanträge eingereicht mit ihnen
steht nicht nur die Reform auf der Kippe
sondern auch die Regierung sollte die
Nationalversammlung am Montag mit einer
absoluten Mehrheit für die Anträge
stimmt wäre die Rentenreform abgelehnt
und die Regierung müsste zurücktreten
das gilt aber als unwahrscheinlich
nach Ostafrika in Mosambik Madagaskar
und Malawi leiden die Menschen besonders
unter dem Tropensturm Freddy er gehört
weltweit zu den Zyklonen die am längsten
gewütet haben mindestens 400 Menschen
starben in den Fluten hunderte werden
noch vermisst besonders schwer getroffen
malavi denn hier zog Freddy gleich
zweimal innerhalb von zwei Wochen über
das Land viele Opfer auch in der
Millionenstadt blendire Verena berichtet
die Gräber in denen sie ihre Angehörigen
beerdigen wollen sind voller Wasser und
es kommt immer mehr sie wollen den
Familienmitgliedern die letzte Ehre
erweisen sie trauern gemeinsam im
strömenden Regen
mein Bruder starb mit seinen fünf Söhnen
ein anderer Mann aus unserer Familie
seine Frau und seine zwei Kinder sind
auch tot wir haben 14 Familienmitglieder
verloren
ganze Dörfer hat der Sturm zerstört der
Schlamm hat nahezu alles unter sich
begraben die Zahl der Toten steigt
täglich mit Hacken und schaufeln graben
sie verzweifelt nach Überlebenden und
Leichen
viele Leute sind im Schlamm begraben wir
könnten sehen als sie in uns
vorbeigetrieben sind im Wasser aber wir
konnten nichts tun
der malawische Präsident nahm an einem
Begräbnis für 21
opferteil er hat den Süden des Landes
zum Katastrophengebiet erklärt bittet im
internationale Unterstützung für sein
Land das zu den ärmsten Ländern der Welt
zählt
man muss einfach weinen weil Angehörige
ganze Familien ausgelöscht worden und so
viele sind betroffen es ist traurig dass
wir die Auswirkungen des Klimawandels so
abbekommen
einige Regionen Malawis sind komplett
abgeschnitten hunderte Menschen werden
immer noch vermisst
wir machen jetzt einen Schnitt sind beim
Sport und dem Hammerlos für die Bayern
in der Fußball Champions League
Christine die Bayern fühlen sich jetzt
schon bereit dafür kein geringerer als
Manchester City mit Stürmerstar oerling
Holland und Trainer pep Guardiola ist
der Viertelfinalgegner von Bayern
München in der Königsklasse auch in
Europa liegt nur noch ein deutscher
Verein dabei nach dem Aus vom SC
Freiburg gegen Turin und Union Berlin
gegen Sergio
Leverkusen kam dagegen gegen Ference
Varos in Budapest weiter in diese
Stadion werden die Leverkusen da wo
möglich zum Europa League Finale
zurückkehren sofern sie auf ihren
Trainer hören diese Mentalität diese
Konzentration
für für Zukunft
streffer nach Sieg im Hinspiel führte
Bayern jetzt mit 13:0 für die Zugabe
sorgte noch an ihn Atli alonso's Team
scheint gut gerüstet für das
Viertelfinale mit Union Berlin Bezwinger
sehr chillouas
Bundestrainer haben sie Flick hat für
die ersten beiden Länderspiele des
Jahres Ende März gegen Peru und Belgien
den Kader benannt darunter 5 Neulinge
die Stürmer Mary Quinn Berisha und Kevin
schade die Rechtsverteidiger Jascha
Wagner und Marius Wolf sowie
Mittelfeldspieler Felix Matscher wollen
natürlich neue junge Spieler aber auch
die wieder dabei sind wie Florian Wert
oder Emre Chan und Timo Werner auch der
verletzt war bei der WM Gelegenheit
geben mit sich ja einfach noch mal zu
zeigen was sie was sie uns geben können
Rang zwei für Skilanglauf
Olympiasiegerin Katharina Hennig beim
Weltcup im schwedischen vorlohn über 10
km klassisch ihr vierter Podestplatz
dieses Winters eine kurze Erholungsphase
nach der WM hat dir gut getan auf den 10
km klassisch ihre Lieblingsstrecke und
dem anspruchsvollen Kurs im
Mittelschweden liegt Katharina Hennig
früh aussichtsreich im Rennen allein
Kerst du niesk Kannen ist nicht zu
schlagen die erfahrene Finnen gewinnt
deutlich Hennig kämpft auf den letzten
Kilometer um ihren Spitzenplatz und
schaffte es die Norwegerin karl war auf
Distanz zu halten Platz 2 die 26 Jahre
alte Sex in beweist erneut dass sie zur
Weltklasse Langläuferin gereift ist
lange Saison noch immer Schnee nichts
mit Frühling dort aber bei uns danke
Ihnen ja morgen soll es tatsächlich
frühlingshaft mild werden bei uns im
Süden gibt es viel Sonne im Nordosten
dann mehr Wolken und Schauer Gewitter
auch noch gleich mehr dazu mit Christa
Orden im heute schon alle um 22 Uhr
erwartet sie später Maria das lomka so
viel von uns schön Start ins Wochenende
und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend heute gab es meist ein
sehr freundlichen Tagesstart bevor dann
eben von Westen die hohen und Mittel
hohen Wolken dichter wurden und es war
schon sehr warm 20,5 Grad im Südwesten
im Schwarzwald in Wolfach nur im
Nordosten da blieb es mit 12 bis 14 Grad
etwas kühler aber diese
vorfrühlingshafte Luftmasse bringt
morgen dann auch hier noch mal etwas
höhere Werte und auch heute Nacht ist es
halt sehr mild in Nordrhein-Westfalen
sinken die Werte nicht unter zehn Grad
nur Niederbayern gibt es leichten Frost
die nächsten Nächte sind dann aber
erstmal frostfrei
dazu gibt es in der Nacht vom
Schwarzwald bis zum Erzgebirge meist
einen klaren Himmel vereinzelt Nebel im
Nordosten gibt's aber dann diese Wolken
die vom Saarland bis zur Ostsee auf
dieser Zugbahn immer wieder schauerartig
verstärkten Regen bringen und das bleibt
dann auch die Zugbahn für die Schauer
morgen das sind keine großen Regenmengen
das schaut auch zwischendurch immer mal
wieder die Sonne hervor wenn sich aber
vereinzelt Gewitter bilden kannst auch
mal ordentlich prasseln und der Wind
Auffrischen der vor allem im Süden
Meister sonst nur aus südlichen Richtung
und schwach weht in Bayern und in
Baden-Württemberg wird es morgen sonnig
und dazu sehr mild diese
vorfrühlingshaften 15 bis 20 Grad im
ganzen Land nur in der Küste sind das
etwas weniger doch in den nächsten Tagen
bleiben wir in diesem zweistelligen
Bereich am Sonntag wird es aber
wechselhafte also auch im Süden dann
Schauer und vereinzelte Gewitter möglich
am Montag zum Frühlingsstart am 20 März
sieht das ganze dann aber nach Osten ab
tschüss